so so this is uh matthew and uh chen
they're from um the keras team um and uh
matthew is a machine learning engineer
who focuses on high-level modeling apis
and he studied computer graphics during
undergrad and has a master's from
stanford
and chen is a software engineer from the
keras team who also focuses on these
high-level modelling apis
and also has a masters in electrical
engineering from stanford and is really
interested in simplifying code
implementations of ml tasks
um so we're really excited to have you
here to sort of help people understand
kind of what keras is you know maybe
convert all the pie torch die hards
and before getting started i just want
to show people um just quickly how they
can ask questions so
if you go to the hugging face forums
you can click on the course
category and then you can scroll down to
where we have matthew watson and chen
cien and here you can just post your
questions and we'll be voting on them
based on likes and then and
also the the forums contain the links to
the to the collab notebooks that my
attention is are going to use
cool so with that i think uh matt your
first right yeah i'll be first so we'll
um add your screen and um yeah we'll uh
see you soon
okay great um yeah let me
actually start the presentation
um okay cool yeah thanks for joining um
yeah i'm i'm matt and i'm speaking with
chen we're both on the keras team inside
of tensorflow um and yeah today we're
going to be talking to you about nlp
workflows inside of the keras library
um so quick just kind of plan for the
day i'm going to do the first part of
this talk and i'm going to be just
talking about kind of building like very
basic models very basic nlp models
inside of keras and showing showing what
that looks like um then i'll hand it
over to chen who's going to talk about
kind of like pre-training and
fine-tuning using hugging face and keras
hopefully all of that will take about
half an hour and then we'll have
questions
um
cool so before i even dive into my side
of the talk i wanted to do two slides
like super quickly just giving an
introduction to takerus to anyone who
hasn't seen this before
um so
yeah first off what is keras um it is a
deep learning api um and the kind of one
sentence version of it is deep learning
for humans um but what that that means
in terms of how we're trying to build
our library is really centering it
around like simple apis that kind of
reduce cognitive load as you're building
up your models so you can focus on
building your models and really trying
to focus on
kind of a minimal number of actions that
you need to take for common use cases so
basically you can get the keras library
and
spin up a lot of examples very quickly
start to kind of explore your problem
space very quickly and that's a key goal
with the keras libraries um and then
another way you can think about it is
that keras is the high-level modeling
and training apis that will come
pre-packaged with tensorflow
um yeah that's keras uh and then i
wanted to also introduce just two kind
of basic abstractions that you'll run
into over and over again with the keras
library um and that's layers and models
um so
yeah you might be you might have seen
something familiar to this somewhere but
basically you can think of layers as
kind of these lego blocks of like common
motifs that you'll see in many machine
learning model architectures um
and with keras you can take these lego
blocks you can combine them in a whole
lot of expressive ways
um
and then yeah snap them together and a
model will be this collection of layers
that kind of map from your inputs to
outputs and the model is going to be the
thing that you can like train that you
can save that has all these highly level
apis available on it
okay so that was a super super quick
introduction to keras the library as a
whole
um now i'm gonna do my my side of the
talk that's on these kind of basic
nlp models we can build with keras um
and i'm gonna be doing this with the
sentiment analysis data set from imdb uh
if you haven't seen this i think it's
like 25 000 reviews in the training data
set that are just movie reviews like
three or so paragraphs of text
describing a movie and we're just trying
to build a model that will predict is
this a positive review or a negative
review
um and my my goal in showing all this is
going to first be to just kind of show
some basic building blocks for keras so
i'm working with texan keras um and then
the main kind of the thesis of my side
of the talk is going to be about this
this triangle on the right hand side
here which is that using keras you can
hopefully go very quickly from an idea
to an experiment to seeing some results
um and use that to inform kind of the
next experiment you run in a nice tight
loop so we'll actually build up like
four
very quick models on on my side of the
talk
okay um so we're going to be
writing this all in code so let's let's
start by downloading our data set um
yeah you can
see what we're doing here is we're first
just downloading a
a bunch of plain text files in a couple
directories and then we're going to use
a keras utility to load them as a
tensorflow data set um
and yeah we're batching things and when
when
data is flowing through tensorflow
you're going to be seeing everything
going through as tensors that's kind of
how tensorflow works and you can see
once we've loaded our data set and
batched it we have these batches of size
32 where every input we have just a
single
input feature coming in for each of our
examples which is a string i i've
truncated it here because they'd be too
long to show reasonably on a slide but
think each string is you know many
paragraphs of text and then each label
is a one or a zero and a one here means
this is positive review is zero means it
was a negative review
okay so we've downloaded it is that you
kind of immediately hit this roadblock
that you'll you know hit every time in
lp which is how do we represent our data
um you're not going to feed strings
directly into any neural network
architecture so you know you need some
sort of transformation of your input
before you can even really start
worrying about your model architecture
um
and one approach that you can use inside
the keras library for this is the text
vectorization layer which we'll see in
code in a second um but yeah it's it's
one of our lego blocks that's kind of
just centered specifically around
working with text input
so it'll do a few different steps there
they're all configurable but by default
it'll have a normalization stage where
you'll remove punctuation and lower case
a splitting stage and i think the
default option will just split on white
space so splitting into different words
um and then there's a number of
different ways you can map from
from that idea of string tokens to some
sort of numeric inputs for your model
and
the the simple model the first thing
that we're going to build you may have
seen this before it's called a unigram
model you'll also see this called a bag
of words model um and yeah it's a nice
simple thing we can build to start
trying to guess if our reviews are
positive or negative where we're
essentially just going to look at what
words are present in a review and what
words are not present in a review so
we're going to build up this vocabulary
of the most common words in all our
reviews first
um and then when we get around to kind
of encoding each individual review we're
going to encode each individual review
as this big long array of zeros and ones
um that kind of aligns with our
vocabulary that we've learned and if you
get a 1 that means that word was present
in your bag
so the word movie is present in this
review we get a 1 at that movie
index good is not present we get a 0.
so that's the rough idea for the model
that we're going to build
let's look at this in code
um
yeah this
is actually a complete training example
for this unigram model but i'll try to
break this down step by step so first
off like kind of the overall flow that
we're doing here is we're going to
define this kind of symbolic input at
the top which is saying that
we have you know our our inputs are a
single feature it's a single element
strength that's going to be coming
through then we're going to transform
our inputs with some layers it's two of
these lego blocks that we're going to
snap together
um
to transform our inputs to outputs we
build a model over our inputs and
outputs and then we train that model
um so that's that's the rough flow um
and then we can step through these two
kind of blocks here the first
first thing here is probably the most
dense which is the pre-processing um and
this is where we're going to use that
text vectorization layer we talked about
so first thing we're doing here because
we're for a second we're just going to
be working with our features and not our
labels because we're going to map over
our data set we're going to toss out the
label just to give us the the plain
reviews alone in a data set um then
we're going to build our first keras
layer and you can see when you're
building a keras layer you normally will
initialize these with some amount of
configuration as to how they're supposed
to work um so this output mode multi-hot
is where we're asking for this bag of
words encoding of our input and then
this max tokens 10000 is just saying how
big do we want our vocabulary to be and
we're saying we want to learn the 10 000
most frequent words
in all of our reviews
and the way we actually learn the 10 000
most frequent words you could actually
supply a vocabulary yourself if you knew
that and you had trained it yourself but
you can also use this utility function
that we have called adapt which is
actually going to loop over all of our
features all of our input reviews and
just learn the 10 000 most common words
that we see in all reviews
so when we've learned our vocabulary
we're ready to actually
call
the text vectorization layer on our
inputs keras layers when you want to
call them you can just treat them as
functions and call them on your input
and that will give us this bag of words
representation that we just talked about
um so from there then we actually still
need to build a trainable model on top
of this
um and the simplest thing we can think
of to do there is kind of just add a
linear layer on top of this and we'll
just call it a day there so we're gonna
yeah we we're mapping each of our inputs
to this 10 000 long array of ones and
zeros and we're just gonna learn a
linear combination of all of those ten
thousand values pass that through a
sigmoid function and that's our whole
model um so yeah just logistic
regression on top of our bag of words
um
yeah so once we've done that we can
define our model
uh compile is a keras function on models
for just kind of setting up how your
training is going to work um so we can
specify our loss function here we can
say we want to track accuracy here and
then we just train for five epics
um so yeah that's a complete code
example in keras i encourage you to try
this out in a collab if you would like
um
but yeah essentially now we've we've
built our first model and we've kind of
made two design choices here we've made
a design choice around how we want to
represent our input data as some sort of
numeric input
and then how do we want the actual
trainable architecture of our model to
look and now we're now that we've built
up our first example we're just going to
iterate on a few different ideas for how
how we can build up our model for the
rest of for the rest of my part of the
talk
um so take one was what we just did
unigram model we're taking in our input
reviews we're mapping into a bag of
words where we're throwing out all of
our sequence data we're throwing out
everything except just what words were
present what words were not present we
don't even care how many times the word
film appears we just want to know is it
in the review or not
um so
this is the exact code i showed you
before i've just kind of zoomed in on
the actual meat of the model here
because we're gonna just be iterating on
this for the rest of the talk um but
what does this look like when you
actually run it how does it perform um
first thing you can notice here is that
it's a very small model that we're
actually training it's just 10 000
parameters because we're just learning a
weight term for each term in our
vocabulary and that's it that's the
whole model um and we're actually
already doing pretty well we've got 89
validation accuracy um on a holdout
dataset um
yeah that was that was take one um and
now we can start doing what hopefully
cares is going to make it easy to do
which is iterate on a bunch of different
ideas kind of explore the landscape of
this little problem that we're working
on
um so take two we can try is a bigram
model um and bigrams are just fancy word
for a pair of words together so if
you're looking at this first sentence
this film is a diagram in this sentence
a travesty is a bigram in this sentence
and we want to build the exact same sort
of bag of words idea but we now also
want to look at bigrams in addition to
unigrams and you could think
how this might be useful already because
not good the bi-gram not good means
something very different than the the
unigram good so by adding in that little
bit more knowledge of our kind of
sequence data coming in maybe we can
build a more expressive model
um so what does this look like in code
we actually have to just make very very
small changes to our text vectorization
layer this is the pre-processing side of
our model definition um and we're just
gonna make two changes here we're gonna
one we're gonna just bump our vocabulary
size we've changed from looking at only
words to looking at words and pairs of
words so kind of our vocabulary space is
a lot bigger so we want to learn a
bigger vocabulary inside of that space
um
and then this engrams 2 argument is just
where we act ask the text vectorization
layer to also look at bigrams as well as
xenograms everything else stays exactly
the same we keep learning our logistic
regression on top
and that is our entire model
so if you ran this in code you would see
okay we bumped the vocabulary size um
from
10 000 to 20 000 parameters
um just doubled our vocabulary size so
we've doubled our model size um but
we've actually bumped our accuracy so
now we're over 90 accurate on predicting
whether review is positive or negative
so that's great it was a nice quick and
successful experiment that we ran
um and yeah now we'll try
two more models on the side of the talk
um
and the first thing what we'll do for
the next two models that we build is
we'll we'll switch from we'll we'll say
forget the bag we're not gonna do the
bag of words model anymore um and we're
gonna do
this very common thing in nlp which is
we're just going to map each word to an
integer index um so we're keeping our
sequence data in our preprocessing
and we have this movie was bad this list
coming in we're going to map each
individual word to an index so this is
the fourth index and our vocabulary so
this maps to a four movie is the first
index it maps to a one and this output
is going to kind of be our pre-processed
inputs that we're working with for our
last two examples here um
okay so
what can you do with integer indices for
words the common thing you'll do
in most models is embed them so we're
gonna take
our input sequence we're going to take
our input string we're going to map it
to a sequence of integers and then we're
going to map each individual integer to
a set of trainable parameters so the
index 11 will map to
in this example for trainable parameters
same with 20. um
i'm going to learn this big long kind of
horizontal embedding that you can think
of where we're just pulling out
individual columns for each word and
hopefully that learns like this rich
but low dimensional space for all the
words that we have coming in um and then
because we're just trying to keep our
models simple on this this side of the
talk we're gonna do the simplest thing
we can think of with our sequence of
embedded words which is just average
them together not even try to do
anything fancier than that
okay so let's dig into this in code um
we still have our pre-processing block
and the the part where we apply our
actual trainable layers
the preprocessing block is going to
change a little bit here
um we're switching our output mode so
this is where we're saying we don't want
our bagged model we actually do want a
sequence of integers coming out of our
text vectorization layer
our vocabulary size will
move to 10 000 and then output sequence
length this is just something to keep
this example simple where we're gonna
say
for every input review
if it's less than 250 words we're just
going to pad this with zeros till it
becomes 250 words and if we get a review
that's longer than 250 words we're just
going to chop it off at 250 words and
that'll just keep training simple here
um and then for the actual trainable
model we have a good bit of new stuff
here
we're using our embedding so this is
where we take each word and map it to an
embedding for each word um rather than
for like on the sliders showing you're
actually mapping to 32 different
trainable parameters for each word
um
we apply some dropout and this is just
because we're building a much
more expressive model with a lot more
parameters here so it helps to bring in
some dropout just to avoid overfitting
and then we're doing this very
simple the global average pooling 1d is
really all it's doing it's taking
everything in your sequences in your
input data and averaging them together
so we'll build that model we'll still
build a logistic regression on top just
to map everything to one single
prediction
and that's our whole model
so if you were to run this um you'd see
we've kind of exploded our parameter
space a bunch because our embedding is
now it's pretty big we have 320 000
parameters compared to 20 000 for our
simple
uh bigram model that we were looking at
last time and we've actually not
improved our our validation accuracy at
all we've gone from 90 with the bygram
model to 87
um
so
maybe not the best line of inquiry to
keep going down further but at least
this was a quick experiment we could run
try out and see how it works
um
okay and then the last kind of model
that we're going to build here is a
recurrent one and
probably not a lot of people in the
stock have seen this before i won't go
too deep into the details of how a
recurrent neural network works or
anything but the idea is we're going to
build this lstm model do the exact same
transformations as we were doing before
where we take our input sequence we map
it to a sequence of integers for each
word each word maps to an integer we map
each integer then to an embedding for
each word which is hopefully this
this low dimensional but rich
representation of each word
and then we feed all of those into this
recurrent neural network which is going
to be a trainable bunch of cells where
we process each word one at a time and
as we're processing the word our our
trainable cell will have some sort of
memory of what it's seen before so
hopefully the lsdm can learn some
interesting things about our sequences
coming in and start to remember what
words had seen a word what words it's
seen before a particular word that it's
looking at in the sequence
um
so that's the idea what does this look
like um in terms of code we'll we'll
keep our input representation exactly
the same we keep our preprocessing the
same we keep our embedding the same
dropout everything's the same except
we're just going to switch out our
pooling layer with a trainable lstm
layer and that will be it
um so if you ran this this is our most
expressive model um yeah we started with
a 10k parameter model and now we're at
336 parameters um and we're actually
doing the worst of all of them with our
biggest model um so we
top out at about 86 validation accuracy
and you can see we're already really
struggling with overfitting
um
okay so that was a just very quick
introduction to what it looks like to
build four different simple nlp models
with keras and again the rough idea and
what we're trying to do with the library
is to make it really easy to run kind of
experiments like this to come up with
some idea for either how you represent
your your input text
but when you feed it into your model how
you pre-process it or an idea for how
you want to actually architect your
model itself and go very quickly from
that idea to some sort of results
so yeah that's entirely what we're
aiming to do with the keras api and you
can already see how it's it's given us
some useful information into our our
problem here where we've found this nice
sweet spot the n-gram models actually
turn out to be when you're not doing
pre-training and there could be a lot of
reasons you don't want to do
pre-training in in
a problem like this um
where you you know we built a model with
only 20 000 parameters that is going to
be incredibly computationally efficient
it'll give you really fast inference
times um and it's already greater than
90 accuracy so
you can play with this more certainly
you can get to even
better accuracy with with engram models
but we've already kind of found this
nice kind of sweet spot to
to go dig into you could try this you
could try more things attention
mechanisms um what not but yeah that was
just a quick quick enjoy trying a few
different simple architectures in karas
um but yeah if you did want to get to
like
state-of-the-art performance you'll want
to do pre-training and fine-tuning so
for that i will hand off to jen
awesome thanks a lot matt
i'll add chin to the stream
um would you like us to do questions for
your section all together at the end i
think we're going to just do questions
at the end of that yeah i'll do together
perfect
right
i'm going to go present here
so i'm just gonna add
uh
jen's
slides great
so
sounds good so take it away thanks cool
uh hi my name is chen in the second half
of the talk i would like to demonstrate
with real code examples on how to deal
fine training with hugging face and
keras
the main takeaway we hope you'll get
from this talk is you will find it
simple to do fine training with
headquarters and the hugging face
we will use the same task as the first
half the imdb sentiment analysis in the
second part
and some background for people not
familiar with fine training the idea is
starting halfway towards our target
instead of building a model from scratch
it's pretty similar to buying a house
imagine you want to buy a house usually
we do not buy an empty land and build a
new house but we buy a house and do the
remodeling the remodeling process is
pretty similar to a fine training idea
and in our time db sentiment analysis
task we can load that pressure and burn
model and build our model on top of it
and what is bert burr stands for
bi-directional encoder representations
from transformers it was published by
google in 2018 and has gained great
popularity in iop community due to its
strong performance explanation onboard
is beyond the scope of this talk the
main thing we need to know is bernie is
very good at extracting representations
from texts or say bird is a good text
encoder
now let's take an overview of the model
architecture we are going to build first
of all we have the tags loaded from imdb
datasets the movie reviews
and we add a special token in front of
each movie named crs we will come to the
purpose of this token very soon
the first layer we have is a bird
tokenizer as we mentioned in the first
half neural networks cannot understand
string input so we need to map this
sequence of into of text into a sequence
of integers it's a job of this per
tokenizer
the second layer is a bird encoder it
takes in the sequence of integers and
map it into a sequence of vectors
and here we only take the first vector
the vector for the cls token to
represent the whole sentence
this is a common lp practice basically
if we set up the model properly the
information of the sentence is going to
be fused into the first token
now we have the vector representation we
add a third layer the fully connected
layer to map the vector into another
space which is usually of a smaller
dimension we call that projective
representation this is going to be our
final representation for input text
and the last layer is straightforward we
input this projective representation
into a soft max classifier the output
would be the probability of this movie
review being positive and being active
that's all for the model
before we look into the code i want to
pause here for a few seconds i want you
to think about one question but how
complex do you think make the model work
is like like how many lines of code do
you expect to write or like how many
hours to expect to spend here i want to
possibly for like 10 seconds and let you
think about it just give it a guess
okay cool now with answer your mind
let's look at the code we have in total
of five steps
the first step is to load the tokenizer
and pre-transfer from hacking face
library as highlighted in the wrap box
if you haven't installed the transformer
library you need to copy and start to
install that and you pick up the model
you want to use and in our case we pick
up the steel bird tokenizer faster than
this still burn model
and if you are not familiar with the
input and output format of the model you
can play around with it this is one
sample output
and the second step is to load imdb
dataset into a memory this part is
pretty similar to the first half so i
will not jump into the details of it but
i want to pause for a few seconds to let
you look at the code
let's go to step three
step three is to tokenize the data set
as highlighted in the red box
as we already have the data and the
tokenizer we can simply import the data
into a tokenizer output like train
codings validation encodings would be
the sequence of integers we described
previously
and we do one more conversion we convert
the data into the format of tensorflow
data set so it can be understood by our
character
a minor detail here starting from this
tensorflow data center conversion every
code is going to be based on tensorflow
and the keras library
now we are going to step four
build our text classification model on
top of the prism bird
to build a class model you want to
subclass the cluster model class
and because we are taking an in external
verb encoder we want to add an argument
named the encoder into the arc list of
the constructor
and we explicitly set the trendable
field as true so that the gradients can
be propagated all the way towards the
pre-chamber model the red bar is
straightforward we have fully connected
layer which is the self.dense one here
and we have softmax classifier which is
self.dense two here and the jaw poly is
a common practice to avoid overfitting
and remember to channel components
together by overriding a call method
it's very simple you just specify the
output of a previous module how to input
to the next module
and we are almost there last step is to
train the model we want to first have a
model instance
and do some configurations like what
optimizer will you use and what the loss
functions you have and some metrics you
want to pay attention to and you come
out of it to get a model trend
and this is output
of this model training process we see
that within two epochs we arrive at a
validation accuracy up around 92 which
is good but we still see the overfitting
problems like say epoxy we see the
training accuracy being 97
but the accuracy is only 91
this is because even though the atoms
like the fully complete is very small
but the bird itself is very big so it
has an overfilling problem
and that's all for the code and we have
shared this code in the forum i would
encourage you to check it out and
especially if you're interested in
building this overwriting problem you
can use this code as a starting point
and write your code on top of it
and that's all for the talk we can go to
the question section
awesome thanks a lot chen and matt for
your really nice talks and careful
breakdown of keras
um got a couple of questions here some
are a bit technical um
so one question is uh
matt you explained this uh text
vectorization class yeah i'll just pop
this in the um here so we can see it so
you know it kind of looks like a
tokenizer
um in some sense and the question is
does it or keras the library more
generally allow users to kind of train
their own tokenizers so if they're
trying to sort of train
bert themselves um yeah they do this
yeah um that's a great question text
vectorization is gonna give you um just
kind of more basic tokenization so it'll
be good if you wanna do like a character
level tokenization or a word level
tokenization um but if you want like
burt on most of these transformer
architectures you're usually going to
want subword tokenization which text
factorization won't do
but there is a library you could check
out called tf text i mean for one you
could use the hugging face tokenizers
for sure there's also a library called
tf text
which you could look at which will allow
wordpiece and sentence piece kind of
inside the tensorflow graph which there
could be times where you want all of
basically your transformations happening
inside the tensorflow graph so tf text
is a way you can do that
awesome and speaking of tensorflow the
next question is uh people tend to use
tensorflow and keras interchangeably
and i was wondering what the differences
are or when should you use one over the
other
um yeah i mean i think the way you can
kind of i mean tensorflow is a broad
term for a large ecosystem but if you
think of the core tensorflow apis
as
being
yeah kind of a lower level keras is a
higher level training api layered on top
of it um
so they're not interchangeable you can
use tensorflow without using keras um
but keras is usually the easiest way to
build a model inside
right yeah i think
oh yeah please
i'm just gonna say i think tensorflow 2
kind of if i unders remember correctly
keras became kind of like a first class
citizen is that correct yeah that that
this is not the case in denver blue one
but the tensorflow that's the new
picture i was about to say in our
initial launch of tensorflow 2 we put
cars and tensorflow together so in that
case we have no difference between that
because you when you want to call powers
you just do tfl kind of things and we
have split the code because like outside
tensorflow the class ripple is not
separate but mainly speaking like for
people building model the first place we
go to is still using the keras because
it's like it has the layer and the model
abstraction there it's more closely
aligned with the building model process
yeah definitely i totally agree like if
you want to you know build an experiment
quickly you just want to just get done
fast you don't want to you know get into
the low level you know graph and stuff
but i think you know from my old
experience in tensorflow 1 using the
graph was really great for performance
reasons
this is maybe more of a philosophical
question um
so since the transformer architecture
took over nlp do you see a good use for
previous models like lstms because i
think matt you showed a pretty nice
example and you kind of answered this a
little bit with this uh you know 20k
parameter or 90k parameter model i think
yeah i mean i think it totally depends
on your problem stuff but in the example
we are looking at like this it's a very
small amount of data and you might be
worried about being doing pre-training
because maybe you you know it's a lot of
kind of extra data to bring in it's hard
to validate you might be worried about
bias um you might be worried about
computational efficiency when you're
doing inference so in this example the
lstm this actually weren't a great way
to go down but the engram models which
are some of the like simplest things you
hit in like chapter one of any nlp
textbook are actually really really
performant and it's good to remember
they're out there if you do want like a
really simple model that you can train
that's surprisingly quite effective
yeah i totally agree i think like one
thing we sometimes forget is like you
know transformers is not like the first
thing you should reach for maybe like
if you're building like a real nlp
application naive bayes with engrams is
like a really strong baseline and
you know you'll often find that the
extra complexity you know causes you
some problems in prod
um
let's see so this is maybe a question
for chen um
so
there's a lot of optimizers out there
these days and is adam really all we
need or should we be looking at other
optimizers because i think you mentioned
in your code when you were building the
model.compile you had adam and yeah i
know that like there's like a history of
adam and adam w and all these kind of
things but i'm just curious like just
generally what do you think about
the space of optimizers and
yes where where this is developing so
that really depends on what you want so
if you want to build a state of our
model atom is definitely not enough but
if you want to play around with uh with
a model i want to try some development
work because atom is good enough but one
thing there even if you are using atom
you may need to look at something called
moving average optimizer which is inside
tensorflow add-on it's just like a
wrapper optimizer but you keep the
moving average of the model variables so
that it gives you some boost in the
performance that's something you want to
look at but if you're looking at
building some state-of-the-art model
maybe you can check out something like
sem sam optimizer and some other like
advanced strategy
i would say like short answer is adam's
still good but if you are looking on
something very advanced you can think
about some other approach
awesome
let me just have a quick look to see
what else we have here
um
[Music]
okay so another question we have is
in
chat give me a sec
so the question is um
can layer wise learning rates help uh
during fine tuning when it comes to bird
models
a short answer is i think it can but it
will be really hard to configure that
probably you should try a lot of times
before you can actually get the model
converged
because
if you are fine training with such a big
model it's very error prone if you set
up like some layer using the wrong
learning rate maybe of some problem but
definitely with at a high level it
should help with the fine tuning process
but
probably not in the aspect of doing the
the speed of making this work but just
like performance the final performance
could be better
yep yeah i totally agree
um and this is another final question
maybe for matt i think in um your talk
you you were explaining you know you had
these learning codes or the validation
um
accuracy and so on and so the question
is can you expand a bit more on this
idea of training loss and validation
loss and if the validation law starts
increasing can we conclude that the
model is fitting
um yeah if your accuracy is going down
and your losses going up on your
validation set that i mean
things can be noisy and you want to look
at how much noisy but i mean in a lot of
our
with the examples i was showing we
weren't doing any pre-training so we
were just looking at this very small
data set of 25 000 input examples um
which is it's really really easy to fit
a overfit at least when you're looking
at
nlp problems so yeah i'm pretty much all
of all of those simple models i showed
if you you keep training for a while you
know notice that you start to be
overfitting a little bit
awesome
and maybe i can ask the last question
it's a it's a personal one so um
like you know working at hugging face i
you know contribute to some of the open
source libraries we have here and
there's always this kind of like um
trying to keep an eye out on the future
of like you know where things are going
so for example you know transformers
there's a lot of developments outside of
nlp and one thing that um i think face
is interested in is like you know
looking at vision and audio and so you
sort of have to make some design
decisions about your library how it
evolves and how do you make sure things
are backwards compatible and i was kind
of curious like in the keras team
like where do you see like the sort of
like the future what are the interesting
like
say domains or
let's say even apis that you find
particularly exciting and maybe you can
shed some light on where where the
library is going
now do you want to talk about like cars
and how people are doing i think yeah i
think well i think one
there there's a number of things that
we're looking at at the keras library um
i mean i think one thing we always
continue to look at which
is separate from from this kind of side
of the talk is just how do you easily
distribute stuff so i think one one
place we continue to have a lot of work
is like you you've written some simple
training example and you want to like
and as quickly as possible take it to
running on a bunch of machines um doing
a multi-work setting we're always
working on that um but yeah another part
that we're looking at a lot is
yeah just kind of
bringing in more high-level abstractions
for for nlp and cv i'm kind of giving
more kind of of these lego blocks that
we kind of give you giving a lot more
that are specific to those applications
to hopefully make it a lot easier to get
get up and running with kind of more
complicated nlp models and and models
computer vision models
and one thing i want to add about
distributed training in tensorflow is we
are trying to
make it like even more seamless
currently you and if you write this
distributed code intense for you need to
call some strategy things i think there
is some ongoing efforts trying to
trying to make that disappear like you
are going to write the same code which
is called the tensor
i like i think it's going to like bridge
the gap between like standard long
training and distribute training and
hopefully that will be much easier in
the future
yeah that would be like awesome because
i i kind of feel that like where we are
now as a field especially in industries
like there's like a kind of like you
know different age of like finally you
get gpus at your company and you know
like for example like you know in my old
job i was a data scientist and you could
get one gpu and you had to share it you
know with like three data scientists
um but you start to see that like now
that companies are really investing
heavily especially in nlp
that this idea of like distributed
training becomes really important
because
you know being able to iterate fast is
is in some sense like the way you make
progress on your problem and yeah i i
think at the moment there's a lot of
like pain in in like you know if you
think to yourself okay i've got my super
nice say keras you know
lines of code you said it's not so much
code and now suddenly i want to scale
out to like you know 20 gpus and then i
i feel like the abstractions are not
quite there yet like at least for me
like i feel like it takes a lot of work
to to build out to that yeah definitely
an area where look at and yeah i mean
keras is really all about that idea the
faster you can iterate is the faster you
can like come up with interesting ideas
so we definitely want to be doing that
in the multi-worker setting
awesome so that's it for the questions
um and yeah thank you once again for
taking part in this community event um
i think it's given people a really great
primer for um how to train models in
keras and tensorflow and we have a
tensorflow scapegoat as we say at
hugging face who's you know responsible
for building all the api part of hacking
page transformers and he's super excited
to see more people um using this so
thanks a lot
cool thanks for having me
thanks a lot for joining
you